[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Django
everywhere Oh God made the gang go and
we have some massive incoming Star Wars
news as of the last hour or so it's just
been confirmed that Tamara Morrison will
be playing Boba Fett in the upcoming
Mandalorian season - before we get into
the story make sure you subscribe to
this channel for videos like this every
day and please drop a thumbs up if
you're as excited as me to see the
return of the most famous bounty hunter
in the galaxy
there's gonna be a lot of new
information on the show coming out of
the next couple of weeks and you
definitely don't want to miss anything
anyway this report comes directly from
The Hollywood Reporter and it says that
Morrison will be playing the character
in the upcoming season which is
currently finished filming the Disney
Plus exclusive is set to see a return of
Fett and it will continue his storyline
after the events of Return of the Jedi
the character supposedly perished in the
Sarlacc pit but according to the new
report he narrowly avoided the digestion
of a thousand years and climbed his way
onto the streaming service to make a big
bad return for the upcoming show many
people when watching the Mandalorian did
wonder where the Fett was back and there
was even the tease that lined up with
his Spurs at the end of episode 5 this
was confirmed to be Mothe Gideon but
clearly fans were desperate to see the
character back and this has now been
confirmed for definite Morrison of
course played Jango Fett an attack of
the clones and we learned that Baba was
cloned directly from him so this casting
makes a lot of sense when watching the
Mandalorian I always hoped that he would
show up and though I thought the season
was incredible I did kind of miss his
presence when we learned that he wasn't
going to be appearing so this kind of
rights the wrongs of that and it's big
big news for Star Wars fans now fed is
expected to play just a small role in
the season and though the amount of
episodes that he's appearing in hasn't
been confirmed yet The Hollywood
Reporter said that it would be a very
minor role still any appearance by the
character in my eyes is big news and
he's one of my favorite Star Wars
characters of all time I always felt he
was kind of poorly handled in the film's
themselves but outside of that in the
expanded universe you really got the
threat that he
caused this definitely makes me excited
for what's to come and yeah it's just
big big news as mentioned earlier the
mandalorian season 2 is already wrapped
filming and the season will be
premiering on Disney Plus in October
this year we aren't waiting on anything
and it was pretty much all finished
before lock downs were initiated so yeah
this is still going ahead the season is
shaping up to be something special and
obviously there are a ton of things that
look forward to this news has really got
me excited and I was just about to go to
bed but I had to report on it now
obviously we will let you know more as
the story continues to unfold over the
following weeks but yeah what awesome
news to get make sure you leave your
thoughts on it in the comment section
below and please drop a thumbs up if
you're as happy as I am if you want
something else to watch after this then
make sure you check out our breakdown on
the recent news about Zack Snyder's
Justice League cut which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over everything
you need to know about it so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you and I said
thanks you get access to content early
every month we give away free movies to
people I subscribe to the channel and
this Monty can win the Marvel phase 3
part 1 box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
serve with notifications on the winners
gonna be chosen at random on the 15th of
May in the cell to be shipped out from
the in to ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]